The sixth issue you have to deal with in doing object design,
is how you're going to implement control. Recall then,
in your analysis model, you may have some state charts. Those state charts
describe the allowable behavior of objects of a particular class.
How are you going to implement that behavior? Regardless of how you do it,
recall that the state that you're dealing with, is essentially,
the possible values of the class's attributes. The ad hoc approach merely says,
write the code, okay? Treat it as each particular situation,
that is each state is detected and you take appropriate events.
So you are essentially implementing by hand that, that state chart.
Fortunately, there are more productive ways to spend your time.
There are libraries that already exist that support finite state modeling,
finite state implementations and you can make use of one of those or
as an intermediate step you could write your own table driven interpreter.
That is the table rows have particular situations that you're in and
corresponding events or
inputs that might arise and the table then tells you what to do or
what to call when that particular, that particular situation obtains